well for minor pain and behavior changes
to really the most severe nerve problems
Chiropractic Care can make a difference
in animals of all sizes in part two of
our special series focusing on holistic
approaches anchor Kirsten Joyce
introduces us to a chiropractor who made
the switch from Human clients to fur
babies
good morning come on in
Orla scan her 10 year old cocker spaniel
Marley make routine visits for
chiropractic care to see Dr Cindy Carter
we'll stop it at the front just like we
do always
um it will spot that Jaws out a little
bit on that right side and we'll get
that adjusted there we go Marley has had
some severe health issues including
seizures two knee surgeries as well as
chemo for underlying issues in her back
legs she's starting to not walk again
because of the pain and the needle they
say it's kind of like a severe burn on
her leg and so that's why we're here to
see Dr Carter she's got a few little
Ribs Right in here
we're getting those ones on the back and
now we have the ones on the front as
well there we go he's those little
muscle particulations those are just
those response to the room Dr Carter
began two decades ago as a human
chiropractor by trade but an incident
with his dog made him rethink his choice
in clients my dog jumps off the bed
hurts his back before work one day and I
didn't have the skill set to help my own
dog he got additional education with the
American Veterinary Chiropractic
Association and is now treating Animals
full time we're going to check
that hip
it's just a little bit stiff there we
got it now she's relaxing now he even
does house calls it all depends the
mobility of the animal and we're just
gonna get that adjusted there we go
and then her tailbone is out as well
we're gonna touch her tail just a little
bit
there we go it's actually quite a bit
stiff
there we got him unlike treating humans
where the corrections can take a lot
longer before one sees any results with
animals I tell most of my clients hey if
we don't see significant results within
three treatments we gotta look at doing
something else because that's how
quickly these uh these things to have a
tendency to start working and since
being adjusted by Dr Carter Marley has
stopped having seizures you run your
hand on your back you feel that little
divot that's that sacred iliac joint
that's what's out on her we do a bunch
of supportive care we walk in slightly
different posture if we've got some
issues going on and we correct those
sort of secondary problems that are
going on we do it for us so why not do
it for them and it's amazing what it
does in the relief almost instantly I
think there needs to be more there there
needs to be more chiropractors for dogs
and how because we love them all so much
I just think it's an incredible
incredible thing that it's a gift you
can give your dog she's all done with me
today
you did it you wanna go play